hello everybody and welcome to squat the
devil or etymon in YouTube's favorite
show that's right everybody to join this
challenge which I've clearly lost cookie
all you gotta do is not alike as well
button that's all you got to do and
you're in that's right now let's begin
the challenge it's got the dude who
didn't fit Keuka deservin all right
clearly you two need therapy so step
into my office
don't rapid please all right
so great I mean he solved couples
therapy and now they don't have to do it
as a couple anymore
thank you for a life in that that joke
that was really funny I know I kind of
seen this
kind of want to see Shrek get married
now it's kind of sad that we will never
see that happen people look at the
problems in the world but what about
Shrek's problem oh my god stay away
x69 oh well saved a princess what
happened to little T she just changed
her style now grown woman now that's
such a weird caption she's still 9 like
comradeship nothing like two brothers
exchanging goods and deeds and valuables
that's inspiring that's not that doesn't
make me laugh that makes me inspired
there is hope for Humanity I think I
discovered my new king everyone please
do send me more photos if there is I
don't see why they're going all know I
was going internally yes more please
some car cars - and beams wow that
sounds like a fantastic combination two
of my favorite things just don't go to
the cinema and enjoy them big problem if
you do morning school sign is supposed
to read sewage plant field trips are
today so can either of you explain why
it now reads yeah the II mean we're
still kicking it apparently still living
still having a good time
great
[Music]
this is your life you lose not you
quench you lose regardless thank you I
know what men can do when they're angry
[Music]
that boogy was that was that boogie2988
dude that looked exactly like boogie2988
I know I know he likes my own do as well
he told me I've seen this one but I
don't remember the punchline that's why
that's why oh my god they're getting
tool getting to over this memes
yeah damn it
[Music]
where's the crying PewDiePie come on I
need to find that mom I mean that
version of for tonight looks fantastic
Wow finally I might be playing for
tonight now why do I look like I have no
ice
what is this happening G says ma she
killed a child
oh my god you kill the children amazing
job you get an S rating fantastic ma she
killed a child
complete that right there is why you're
the best boss this is why Japanese games
are the best
I don't need another version of the Wii
one thank you I will not accept this I
say no I say no to this one I don't need
a Korean version of it Jesus Christ man
it's not just Western civilization that
is ruin it's come clear now wait wait a
minute wait wait
excuse me why are you searching sexy
Garfield I mean why wouldn't you he is
pretty attractive out of all cartoons
I've always had a fun in turist in
Garfield sorry I thought we were
admitting our darkest secrets triple up
hey guys welcome back over control let's
play but steadily using a pecker and
which combo to take out some enemy and
oh [ __ ] my up just prays that we just
restore that
I'm so ashamed that I like that
goddamnit
why did I laugh at that why did I sink
so low I say that I don't like overly
loud and Here I am laughing at it I'm a
hypocrite I'm a fool I'm a peasant I'm
scum I'm little scum scumbag good
anyway let's watch some more clips just
let the e die please he's already dead
actually I didn't mean for that I was
insensitive him hey Vsauce Michael here
take a look at this mm-hmm simple enough
right but watch what happens next
I knew it I know it I know it
what's the heck is this thing ladies and
gentlemen we got him we went from mother
and son to father and daughter okay fine
that was a good Ally I haven't seen a
good ally in a while haha loud noises
not funny
stop doing it or else ah ah is that
funny to you
hi why'd you laugh and then
what
[Music]
be careful what do you
why am i laughing nothing funny is
happening that was actually good now
you're ruining the stop you need to know
when to end them alright well speaking
of knowing when to end it dad gonna end
this video here if you enjoy watching
leave a like and I'll see you next what
leave a like if you loose and if you
like if you lost and let me know if you
lost in the comments let me know now I
will have to go and I'll see you
tomorrow with another video what am I
going to do tomorrow well you're just
gonna have to wait until then to find
out
[Music]